[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we have casey not see today and today's
off the record is sponsored by roman so
Roman is AED service which stands for
erectile dysfunction and it's way more
common than you think over fifty two
percent of men over 40 experience IDI at
some point and then the hard part is a
lot of guys are kind of shy to get
treatment cuz you gotta call the doctor
and it's in the room and people are
looking at you and then you guys do you
have that being and it's just like
there's so much stigma around it a
doctor will decide if treatment is
appropriate and they can prescribe
medication and they'll just ship it
straight to your house with free two-day
shipping so go to get Roman comm / OTR
for free online visit and free two-day
shipping go check them out and then you
don't have to be shy about what you got
going on because you're doing the
privacy of your own home yeah don't put
it off any longer I actually had a tea
when I was 23 well I'll tell you the
truth because you don't know you're
holding it in the truth finally what
happened when you had 80 were you on
ecstasy inexorable just got diagnosed
but I know it's Edie because I thought
this is it I'm old
my dick is dying on me what happened
well okay so it was just weird to me cuz
I was like having sex and like is just
kind of like died they would never get
like hard hard like it was just kind of
getting it for like a period of time
yeah anything like I would jack off and
stuff like that I'm just like halfway
through I'm like and then my health was
really [ __ ] bad because I was working
a lot of graveyard yeah I stopped
working out heavily like you know eating
bad [ __ ] and I I actually went to the ER
at the time cuz I got sick for like two
months straight oh my god yeah so I was
I was going through some crazy health
problems and it was all due to stress
and just not like seeing the Sun and
eating healthy and working out no cuz at
that time I was already off the drugs
and [ __ ] like that
so I was just I think just you know
working graveyard working late
you know I at that time I
just finished like I had a business the
business crashed I went off to like
waiting tables like I used to I used to
make good money I had like I was a I was
also like a manager at a warehouse and
[ __ ] like that
quit that job that all that decided to
go work at a restaurant to be with young
people right but like working graveyard
really [ __ ] with your health that [ __ ]
like and the stress of just all of that
[ __ ] I think yeah anxiety and like in
like in like depression even like maybe
yeah well cuz like I can I feel like on
that because like I feel like I went
through like IDI as well yeah especially
when me and Sarah for I'm doing so well
like like the depression and the anxiety
of just being in the same room together
like we I've never got horny never felt
like me to do any protecting it yeah
really Beto was just super low whenever
we were we were just you know unhappy
with each other yeah it wasn't like I
didn't think you weren't you weren't
sexy anymore like you were so sexy but
like oh you are so sexy nice smooth it
was able to catch those things I'm not
even able to catch just he was talking
about when he had that thing great
couple very good joke
Sookie uh-huh but yeah I don't know I
get and then and then now that we're
kind of past that I I think we're still
kind of lingering in it in and out of it
but now it's like having a better
understanding of like I actually read up
on you do to there enough times like oh
it's all psychological cuz when I quit
that job and I started to sleep regular
all that [ __ ] I was like jacking off
like a [ __ ] and I was like thank
God like I literally was I thought I was
gonna my am down my life was over
I can't jack off anymore that's like
everything that's the quent
quintessential thing Yahoo as a man is
yeah I mean like I love jacking off so
much that even while I had a girlfriend
I still need a jack off yeah
it's like two different things for sure
once playing have all the other ones
[ __ ] monkey bars you got to do both
you can't just have one incest
experience yeah once another ball the
other ones [ __ ] basketball you can't
just have one game did you ever have
that I think I had Edie and I know it's
psychological because I tried jacking
off the gay porn and I couldn't get it
up that's a game poor no as usual I
think we're all over here I think you're
just a little bit over there I think
it's fine
oh dude does that haven't has that ever
happened to you like where you're just
not even turned on at all because like a
psychological thing to me um yeah yeah
for sure when I was in a depressive
state like the last thing I ever wanted
was to have sex for sure um yeah and
then once things started getting fixed
then I was like oh I'm back again you
know cuz I was like a big horn dog yeah
and then it just was like nothing yeah
yeah I never understood like people
having angry sex you know like there's
like a term for that the makeup sex or
makeup sex you know I'm so angry with
you I'm gonna I'm gonna pound you and
all that I do that yeah where do you
what do you tap into anger is one of my
primary motivators and so when it comes
to sex a good hate-fuck is very fun for
me I really but it's not no I don't
think it's real hate I think it's like
no same way that you hate your family
member in a way cuz you still care and
love for them like when use when you
have real hate yeah it's not like
disappointment
[ __ ] that's Paul what it is what for
mater yeah like it's not you're not
actually angry no no no in the moment
I'm I'm like raging on this chick yeah
it's not it's not disappointed I don't
know if I could be angry and also a rose
at the scene because I'm I'm angry I'm
disgusted I'm just like say here like
I'm really trying to run away from you
no see that's different for me because I
I don't know like even when I'm moving
something around lifting something if I
use a little bit more anger I can do I
can finish it yeah yeah working out the
same thing as [ __ ] - my dick gets
smaller
yeah you get on horn like I don't I
don't go like whoa get ready to like
deadlift and then
all of us have a boner from deadlifting
noting that the deadlifting process
itself gets me horny it's that when me
and Nikki are in that mode I get to a
angry place because it's passion but
it's also like I don't even like her
right now
Oh in a hot way she loves that oh my god
she loves that [ __ ]
yeah I mean it is it is it just more on
the specific less respectful sex thing
but is it on a spectrum of more
aggressive than it is real hate and
anger yeah yeah of course so it's not a
hatred but it's hate [ __ ] as like not
actual hate [ __ ] but like that's what
hate [ __ ] is supposed to be how to do
it that's what they call it
yeah yeah you kind of its kind of
pretending with what the feelings are
real
like if you if you were to watch it per
se you'd be like oh wow he's really you
know he's really going hard on that
chick but it's not like and she likes it
yes exactly you take Halle does she take
it as in like is she also angry no good
she loves that she's hitting you back
she's laughing she's trying to yeah but
she's just getting bounded so do you
guys have to make up a fight before
having sex no we just go into it and
wait the more we go into it like
sometimes she wants me to be like more
loving and stuff which we do but then it
usually ramps up to that usually
typically depends that's interesting I
wish I knew how to do it you said you
know how to do it right uh yeah I can I
can relate to that episode are you
tapping in so you hate me but he's not a
[ __ ] no wait it's not a real hate no
it's just the passion behind it yeah you
know but there's like a love passion and
then there's like a hate passion if you
will so it's just a very strong emotion
it's like let's say I left the toilet
seat up and I pedal it over the floor
and you're like [ __ ] I need to
[ __ ] them it's not method acting it's
like that what is it's just in the
passion of the moment you're down to do
to give your partner what they want what
the way you know they want which is
Nikki being domination wants to be a
burly dominated and so I'm like happy to
do that
that could dominate her but I'm not no
but your domination we still got to work
on that nominee
it's not sexual about it's not sexually
it's it's like real domination where I'm
like well sorry yeah [ __ ] yeah you know
when he said it I got scared yeah like
yeah yeah he doesn't know how to he
doesn't know he only knows how to tap
into super soft which is CUNY or like
[ __ ] I got guns the only reason why I
trained is because I want to punch
through a windshield to get the guy out
with one arm like there's only those two
so we're working on the middle ground
like two modes you need a third a third
mode yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
intense
i watch you at Nikki's like of course
you can't you just can't touch me I do
okay I'll try to teach you with the fuzz
so here what you do with a clipboard
yeah he would you just copy exactly what
you do anybody like sexually watch me
[ __ ] Mickey it's part you would
technically examine be turned off I know
that I know the man he's great man i'ma
deal with my eyebrows up like this see I
know that and you'll [ __ ] stop you in
the middle excuse me guys excuse me um
yeah when you slapped her butt yeah was
that out of anger absolutely that's so
hard he would and you and then the next
day like afterward I would get a text in
the morning about how he was thinking
about the Mia Nicki's sex and how he had
some additional questions about
lasted five minutes like do I want to
hit a five minute mark he's like why did
you do that thing where you put your
hand over our mouth you said shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] whoa I'm [ __ ] you did
you really want her to be quiet do you
really want her to be quiet at that
moment right were you just saying that's
mark I I realize you wrapped it up in
speed like was that like to show like
the dominant side or were you just horny
I noticed you flipped honor I notice you
flip turn aside you put a pillow over a
head and you said I don't even want to
[ __ ] look at you I just need to come
did you not want her to breathe like for
real like no hope I still love her okay
okay okay to learn yeah man yeah we're
working on it
that's so good how do you like cuz then
there's also like educational materials
out there dear what happened to that uh
no cuz I like right now it's more of
like I just want us to learn with each
other type thing
yeah it's like you're in what I like
great and you're like having make-out
sessions and like oh I like it like that
yeah yeah yes right huh didn't you say
that you're both dominant personalities
in the bedroom I know I'd like to be
well for me I'm like I like to turn it
on or turn it off depending on what it
is sometimes like two dominates and for
the most part I liked it that's the word
I like to be dominated switch yeah
you can't handle when I dominate him cuz
he wants a buzz like really she's really
good on me sorry I have to at the turn
it down so it's gonna be like it's a
couple of milliseconds but like oh no
the dominations too damn good oh you
dominate my dick with your mouth it's
completely dominated
yeah yeah side side know how to pull it
back that's crazy
do you like being dominated or trying to
tell you the thing you're just gears
your sometimes like afraid that I won't
like certain things cuz I get turned off
immediately like you you really I talked
to a lot of friends and morning sex is a
very common thing where the guy just
kind of sneaks over and kind of but it's
not again I don't think it's common that
girls have previous trauma from the
previous relationship and they have
expressed true that they have woken up
with dicks inside of them and when they
do not consent to that true very
particular like sensitive unique true we
are in a very sensitive territory with
sex huh are you saying that because
you're a [ __ ] near in the morning way
morning in there yeah that's when
everyone's testosterones like carny
schedule that they were kind of off to
you ideally so here in the morning to
warn be your midday mines midday to but
then we're just not together midday yeah
I'm an afternoon to evening horny guy
like at night I'm so tired
I'm just pass out saying I mean I do
morning boners and show of course I mean
I'm a human but the idea of [ __ ]
stinky is not fun it's not yeah that's
that - I like after shower sex yeah yeah
yeah I don't want [ __ ] else thank you
especially because there's a lot of oral
involved oral especially with your body
hmm oh my god my favorite yeah
definitely more midday but then ends up
happening at night cuz then that's just
the time that we have time but then
you're really tired at night and then so
it's really hard to think of it's hard
because like in that Red Bull it's like
by nighttime we've dealt with work it's
all had our bickering
throughout the day or this is the real
[ __ ] though man we talked with Isaac and
some like just like all that images like
in my head don't really add up to being
horny but in the morning though maybe I
just had like a fantasy dream you know
or whatever so I wake up and you're
right there I smell you am I ready to go
ready to go I'm on the program but then
you're such a morning on machine really
has to be very careful with that though
because there's a lot of trauma and that
comes with yeah I'm like just wake me up
just be like good morning it's like wake
me up so spacing miho-chan well I'm just
like I'm letting kids you know maybe
kids need to tell her his name doesn't
forget I don't forget was next to me
it's just the whole thing is like not
having my consent like I have a thing
with that I have a trauma with that so I
was just like wake me up let me know
what you're trying to do but the other
added layer oh no I know girl I told
them yeah sorry you know what we're
gonna deconstruct this burrito right
here he's a really good morning person
you just bring up out of bed and like
it's a beautiful new day I have a clean
slate my mind is fresh let's take on the
day to Disney Princess yes he really is
so I'm a complete opposite because I
still like if for example if we had a
bickering the day before which you know
we tend to not very really resolve
things last night - yeah exactly
actually yeah that's very accurate we
still have some lingering [ __ ] drove
separately today oh oh that [ __ ] it's
like face it and let's address it and
let's work on it and I just be like hey
I'm sorry with that not being of genuine
sorry just like hey I'm sorry just get
over it you know I can't do that and it
just angers me even more and so anyway
so for me I can't wake up with the clean
slate because I'm carrying the [ __ ] from
the day before so that's part of it and
then the other part is that I'm just
really not a morning person like I'm one
of those people it's like don't talk to
me until have my coffee kind of people
so that's the other layer of like damnit
we can't really have sex in the morning
because I have like caramel Isildur [ __ ]
and I just can't get turned on if I have
all this [ __ ] in my head yeah diversion
where it's like my vagina [ __ ] closes
up like we can't get DeeDee China dry
vd yeah you got issues too man you know
what's crazy you know like in my 20s if
I heard any of this [ __ ] [ __ ] I would
have been like that's cuz you guys
aren't really in love oh dude I used to
be so stupid because in reality when you
[ __ ] get with something someone lived
with them all this [ __ ] that's when
you're like oh [ __ ] this is reality
everyone [ __ ] goes through this [ __ ]
but no one talks about it and everyone
lies and pretends friends that I tell
them about like oh well I'm just not
like turned off on my girlfriend anymore
you know because like they live with my
previous lived in with my previous
girlfriend in my room my other roommates
were like why you're not [ __ ] every
day I'm like no man we haven't [ __ ]
for like a whole week two weeks
sometimes you know like how can you not
like you're like there's a there's [ __ ]
right next to you you know um I feel bad
talking about myself like damn what's
wrong you got [ __ ] guilt yeah [ __ ] all
day and I'm not [ __ ] maximizing my
[ __ ] [ __ ] that leash you're letting
your child self down exactly exactly so
now my child self I used to think man I
can't wait till I have a boyfriend like
make out with him so many times
throughout the day it's gonna be like at
least a thousand times and I'm like yes
so so idealistic man it's it's [ __ ]
yeah and with crazy is um it seems that
like the more you fight to fix things
it's like that's when you're really
[ __ ] in a relationship and you're
working towards making it better and you
don't want to do that with anyone else
and um yeah like Joe is saying like it's
dope that we're talking about it cuz no
one really talks about it and you think
like damn everyone's relationships so
perfect why is mine such a piece of [ __ ]
but it's like now man we all just have
issues and we're all bringing our own
issues to the table and now it's like a
relationship that we have to like work
this [ __ ] out I mean it definitely helps
to have a bunch of honest friends that's
willing oh yeah issues because everyone
[ __ ] pretends and everyone pretends
as if they don't have problems that's
the [ __ ] real issue because you look
at their relationships and you go like
oh man I think something's wrong with
mine because everyone else looks happy
and you're like maybe we're not like
right for each other
it's not really like just faking it like
for example I with just within our own
friend group like for me personally I
just feel like I don't want to burden
people with my [ __ ] got to like it
yeah well you know I think I just got to
deal with my [ __ ] then cuz I don't want
to burn another people but and
especially cuz everyone's friends with
everyone so that was kind of where I was
coming from not necessarily you're like
yeah perfect relationship it was just
like well yeah we have our problems and
you'll see me depressed but you don't
have any shame in talking about your
problems which is very different from
people who fake it like they bury that
[ __ ] and they act like nothing's
wrong ever but off-camera I mean we'll
talk about this [ __ ] right like it's
only recently that we decided to talk
about it out in the open but I I think
that is what keeps like the friendship
and all that stuff closer to is being
[ __ ] real and helping each other out
with these things you heard me yeah it's
also toots when you have problems if you
don't resolve them there's so much
damage later and that's why I know
exactly what you guys are talking about
because I've been in relationships like
that but with me and Nikki throws no
there's no blemishes coz you mean here
if everything as we go and so there's no
like I don't have anything against her
like I'm like all see she's doing it
again or anything yeah it's all just
love man and that's what she's got for
me like and that's only because we
handle those things like [ __ ]
surgeons and we get the bullets out
every time and we make sure that we heal
the wound yeah the only way you really
can get there is doing that got it reset
the button both are really into wanting
to resolve it yes yes two different
times though you want to resolve it on
that in that moment in the heat of the
moment I don't I I can't even cool down
a little protocol down under she's
nervous you have to set a time it has to
be later than 20 minutes for less than
24 hours and that never happens in 30
minutes or I say 40 minutes I'm gonna
get home tonight we will work on it I'm
gonna text you guys dope that makes me
feel better cuz I really have been
holding on to anger this whole [ __ ]
day I also think that you should just
let good morning sex go whoa it doesn't
need to it does
need to [ __ ] with you like it is look if
it's if that's a limit for her where
she's like hey man this just isn't gonna
work out for me like you could just let
it go and then you can start to work
your way towards regular methods better
time exactly at a better time at a
different time and have a healthier
relationship with with even that concept
of wanting sex and then she's not gonna
be anxious when she's thinking about oh
it's morning time Casey just woke up
he's like touching my shoulder that
brings anxiety into you and turns you
off right really it's like anxiety well
cuz I'm sure she's trying to please you
too and if she cannot course and then
gets off of your relationship wait table
and now you can work on other [ __ ] yeah
could it's not that it'll be like that
forever it's just right now it's way too
sensitive to approach even that yeah
once everything's clean like then you'll
feel safe and ready to just do anything
I'm doing my personal there were doing
couples therapy we're also doing
personal therapy and so like I'm working
through that trauma but you just got him
some time yeah morning sex is not no sex
it's like Devon sex later that's sex in
ten hours
yep it's pretty tight I'll just wake up
way later like and that will be my
morning sex like yeah yeah instead of
like 6:00 in a more get morning would
like yeah yeah yeah that's really good
sorry guys Romania for writing sessions
no more tip it's [ __ ] 2:30 you're
being a [ __ ] haha
and you have a right to say that Suzie
meet in the middle row
[Music]